K
ACCOUNTS CANCELED.
HAVE YOU EVER SEEN THESE MARVEL
MOVIES OUT THERE?
THERE IS A WEIRD THING WHERE
THERE ARE ALTERNATE UNIVERSES.
HOW DID THE X-MEN NOT SEE THE
ATTACK ON NEW YORK?
REMEMBER THIS?
CHECK THIS OUT.
>> I'M PETER PARKER, I'M
SPIDERMAN.
IN MY WORLD.
>> REALITY CAN BE WHATEVER I
WANT.
DAN: THESE ACTORS COULD BE IN
THE BIDEN WHITE HOUSE, TOO.
THESE GUYS ARE FULL OF CRAP ALL
THE TIME.
THERE IS THE REAL UNIVERSE AND
THE FULL OF CRAP.
THE BIDEN UNIVERSE.
THEY ARE FULL OF CRAP ON
INFLATION.
BIDEN IS ALWAYS CHATTING ABOUT
INFLATION LIKE HE DID SOMETHING
TO STOP IT.
HE GIVES A SPEECH TALKING ABOUT
HOW REPUBLICANS IF THEY GET IN
OFFICE WILL MAKE INFLATION WORSE
WHICH IS WEIRD.
BECAUSE INFLATION WAS 1.2% YEAR
OVER YEAR BEFORE THIS GUY TOOK
OFFICE.
IT'S NOW 7 POINTS HIGHER.
HE SAID WE HAD TO PRINT A WHOLE
BUNCH OF MONEY TO INNATE AWAY
THE DOLLAR BECAUSE THE ECONOMY
NEEDED HELP.
THAT'S NOT RIGHT EITHER.
THE ECONOMY WAS GROWING AT 6%
ANNUALIZED BEFORE YOU TOOK
OFFICE.
NOW WE ARE SHRINKING.
IT'S THOUGHT JUST INFLATION THEY
LIE ABOUT.
THE ALTERNATE UNIVERSE.
THE REALITY UNIVERSE AND THE
FULL OF CRAP UNIVERSE BIDEN
LIVES IN.
SADLY GAS PRICES ARE GOING UP
AGAIN.
WE ALL GET HURT BY IT.
INSTEAD OF USING THE NATIONAL
GASSAGE WHICH IS GOING UP.
IF YOU SPENT TIME IN A
STATISTICS CLASS IN COLLEGE,
THEY DIDN'T PICK THE AVERAGE,
THEY PICKED THE MOST COMMON GAS
PRICE.
FOLKS, NOBODY DOES THAT AS A
MEASURE OF GAS PRICES.
>> GAS PRICES ARE DOWN NEARLY
$1.20.
AND THE MOST COMMON PRICE IS
$3.29 A GALLON.
TAKING STOCK OF WHERE GAS PRICES
ARE TODAY.
THE MOST COMMON PRICE FOR RETAIL
GASOLINE IS $3.29.
DAN: DID YOU CATCH IT?
NOT THE AVERAGE.
THE MOST COMMON PRICE.
I HEARD SOMETHING LIKE THAT IN
MY STATISTICS CLASS IN COLLEGE.
IF YOU LIVE IN AN ALTERNATE
UNIVERSE YOU PICK THE MEASURE
THAT GIVES YOU THE RIGHT.
THIS ONE REALLY AGGRAVATES THE
HELL OUT OF ME.
IT INVOLVES PEOPLE DYING.
CRIME.
WE'LL BE COVERING SOME OF THESE
ISSUES TONIGHT.
IT'S OPTIONAL FOR SOME OF THESE
CITIES TO SUBMIT TO THE FBI.
THEY ARE CRIME NUMBERS.
I FIND IT STRANGE THAT THE FBI
CRIME STATISTICS DIDN'T INCLUDE
L.A. AND NEW YORK.
IF YOU LIVE IN THE FULL OF CRAP
BIDEN UNIVERSE, NOT THE REAL
UNIVERSE WE ALL LIVE IN, HIGH
PRICES AND INFLATION AND PEOPLE
BEATING THE CRAP OUT OF EACH
OTHER BECAUSE THEY CAN'T GET
CRIME UNDER CONTROL.
IT WOULD BE GOOD TO INCLUDE TWO
OF OUR BIGGEST CITIES.
CRIME PICTURE NATIONALLY, BIG
CITIES NATIONALLY.
DON'T YOU THINK IT'S STRANGE
THEY LEFT THEM OUT?
WHEN YOU LIVE IN THE FULL